e
okay good morning everybody Welcome to
Transportation uh we have a busy day
this will be an executive session on
hopefully the balance of our bills
before we get started I'd like to uh
welcome a few of our Replacements today
for Eric Johnson we have representative
Gerard we have for representative kogre
representative L
on and for representative St Clair we
have representative new welcome to
Transportation oh yeah uh so with that
being said if I can have representative
thank you very much for
that and without further Ado I'm going
to open up the executive session on
House Bill 212 allowing a 180-day
operation waiver when a motor vehic a
motor vehicle fails an emission control
test chair recognizes representative
Gorski for a motion thank you Mr chair
I'd like to uh make a motion of retain
on HP uh 212 motion is retained do I
have a
second seconded by representative Hill
care to speak to your motion sir yes
thank you sir thank you Mr chairman um
basically the prime sponsor with this
particular Bill feels like there's still
some modifications that could be made to
make it a little bit better and would
like a little bit more time and So based
on that I think we should retain it to
see um if those adjustments can be made
to make it
better fair enough anybody else from the
committee seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the role when she's ready the
motion is to retain House Bill
212 uh Vice chairman Gorski yes the
clerk votes yes representative Hil yes
representative foot yes representative
poo yes representative Leon yes
representative uh G yes sorry
representative Hamlin yes representative
Sykes yes representative
n yes representative Fox yes
representative Au yes representative
Gerard yes representative common yes
representative Miller yes and chairman
zero okay so our motion of rettin is
adopted 160 I'll close the executive
session on House Bill
212 uh we'll go in order for now uh so
give us a couple of minutes and we'll go
okay I'll open up the executive session
on House Bill 249 allowing bicyclist to
treat stop signs as yield signs and stop
lights as stop signs uh chair recognizes
representative pataro for a motion thank
you Mr chair I move itl on hb24 49
motion isn't expedient to legislate is
there a
second seconded by representative hlin
would you care to speak to your motion
sir uh thank you Mr chair briefly um uh
one of the things that stuck out during
the hearings for this one is that um to
our knowledge and to everybody's
knowledge who spoke nobody's ever been
cited for um this kind
of uh Behavior Uh apparently it's never
happened and so
um all of a sudden us allowing it could
have vast
unintended consequences for uh the
motoring public so that's why I am
itl thank you sir anybody else from the
committee representative Miller thank
you Mr chairman um as this was my bill
I'm certainly disappointed to hear that
response to it uh I think the data
dramatically supports that the uh
closest thing to unintended consequences
is a better flow of traffic uh it
improves safety it makes traffic flow
better uh I'm disappointed to hear that
the committee feels that that data is
insufficient and
inaccurate fair enough anybody else from
the
committee seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the role when she's ready uh the
motion is inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill
249 Vice chairman Gorski yes the clerk
votes yes representative Hill yes
representative foot yes representative
vataro yes representative Lon yes
representative uh G no representative
Hamlin yes representative
Sykes no Representative nle no
representative Fox no Representative auu
no representative
no representative hondon
yeah representative Miller no and
oh okay I missed
the well missed okay um our our U
recommendation of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 249 is adopted
9-7 obviously that'll be regular
calendar I will close the executive
session on this um yeah just no will
there be a a Minority Report there will
be a minority report and will be in
debate and I suspect it'll be from
Miller to to complete so uh minute to
it okay I'm going to open up the
executive session on House Bill 298 FN
creating an
exception to the prohibition on removing
Vint tags from Vehicle Manufacturer
prior in 1981 where removal is
reasonably necessary for repair or
restoration chair
recognizes
representative hlin for a motion uh
thank you Mr chair chairman I would like
to vote that we retain this
Bill thank you sir did you want to speak
to
it so
on the face of it this was a good idea
for sorry about that let me back you up
okay I'm I'm still a little caffeine
Jitters here can I get a second the
motion is to
retain seconded by representative gon
sorry about that that's okay so on on
the face with this bill provides a good
service to repair shops restoration
shops however with the current state law
in New Hampshire there is some work that
has to be done on this bill as far as um
allowing
um the fact that we can take the Vint
tag off and put it back on again thank
you thank you anybody else from the
committee representative
SES
thank realize I left it on thank you um
good thing I was sitting here quietly uh
change so not and and you realize what
you just did would made it made it
really hard for me to be
quiet um actually we um my position
would be that we should itl this bill um
it has enough holes in it that I'm not
sure that we can fix it even with the
retention effort but uh in in view of
that motion we I I will support the
retained motion to we'll give it the a
college try but I'm not optimistic
thank you represent s and I do agree
with you the way it's currently written
I couldn't support it either um we need
to in my opinion um keep the Integrity
of the VIN tags which is the whole
reason for having them uh so uh uh I
think it is worth taking a look at so
I'm hoping we can uh move on with a
ringing so you know it was on silent and
and the volume was all the way down um
that being said anybody else from the
committee seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the role when she's ready the
motion on 298 is to
retain Vice chairman Gorski yes the
clerk votes yes representative Hill yes
representative foot yes representative
pataro yes representative Lon yes
representative um gon yes representative
Hamlin yes representative Sykes yes
representative new yes representative
Fox yes representative a yes
representative Gerard yes Representative
pandon no representative Miller yes and
chairman Walsh yes okay it's 15 to one
okay uh our recommendation of retain is
adopted 15 to1 um I will close the
executive session on House Bill
298 and we will move into house B 411
okay I'll open up the executive session
on House Bill 411 FM relative to making
the use of mobile electronic device the
use of mobile electronic device while
driving a secondary offense chair
recognizes representative Crawford for a
motion thank you Mr chairman my motion
is itl on House Bill 411
FN the motion is in expedient to
legislate do we have a second second
representative by second by
representative SES here to speak to your
motion representative Crawford uh to me
um a secondary offense would be actually
kind of foolish because let's face it if
someone gets stopped for a headlight out
or even for speeding um if I'm using my
phone at the same time and I know I'm
being stopped I'm certainly going to
throw my phone someplace else because I
don't want uh the police officer to know
that I was texting while while I was
speeding so um the whole um reason for
having the hands-free law is to be able
to see someone using this and to be able
to stop them on a primary offense so
that's why I recommend itl on this
bill anybody else representative SES yes
and um one thing that's really important
for us to remember and I appreciate the
what um the support for an itl motion
that um it is documentable that since
this bill was passed um wow I think
maybe more than a decade ago there have
been
demonstrably positive results in terms
of fewer deaths or crashes from
distracted driving and so I think that's
an important tool to keep in the
department of safety's toolbox and help
protect uh people and children who are
otherwise blameless while they drive
down the road from people people who do
not follow the
law thank you sir anybody
else with this why shouldn't jinx
it um I'll ask the clerk to call the
role when she's ready the motion is
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
411 Vice chairman Gorski yes clerk votes
yes representative Hill yes
representative foot yes representative
pataro
yes representative Lon yes
representative God why do I keep
representative Hamlin yes representative
syes yes representative n yes
representative Fox yes representative
Veo yes representative Gerard yes
representative panden yes representative
Miller yes chairman Walsh yes consent
160 and consent okay our recommendation
of any expedience the legislator adopted
16 to zero I did hear consent any
objection to consent seeing none consent
that goes I'll close the executive
session on H
okay I'm going to open up the ex itive
session on House Bill
414 prohibiting the division of motor
vehicles from suspending a license on
the basis of debt Ed to a private entity
relating to the towing or storing of a
motor
vehicle chair recognizes representative
Gorski for a motion thank you Mr chair
uh my motion for HB 414 is
itl motion is inexpedient to legislate
is there a
second that's I heard representative
foot first thank you sir representative
can speak your motion I do thank you Mr
chairman um regarding 414 you know we
had testimony um from people who said
how they've been impacted but I I
actually had a chance to talk to some
Towing uh companies and kind of wanted
to get their view on things and you know
their view
is U first of all this is kind of like
the very very very did I say very enough
uh Last Resort that they kind of go to
in order to try to recoup
um some of the expenses for the towing
and storing um what they all told me was
we try to work with the person um their
goal is not trying to take their license
away from them um but their goal is to
try to work with the person to try to
make something Equitable so they could
uh get their vehicle because the longer
they keep it the longer it's costing
them so um they really felt this uh from
what I when I talked to them this was
kind of something that uh was a
necessary tool but again they Ed at the
very last resort and based on getting
that information um I felt uh this bill
probably should be
ited thank you sir rep
s yeah so um I would be opposed to this
uh itail motion because um we are trying
really hard I think as a legislature to
examine the circumstances under which a
person loses the privilege to drive and
we are trying really hard to make sure
that those privileges are suspended or
Lost based on a moving violation versus
an actual a fine problem um this to me
falls under that kind of category where
um persons may lose their driving
privileges because they have been unable
to pay a bill owned to a private company
or un or owed to for a fine of some sort
and that Vehicles get towed for lots of
reasons none of which inv many of which
do not involve moving violations at all
so it's a it's a in my mind a slippery
slope that we were we we are have fallen
into and I think that we should take
appropriate anybody else from the
committee representative Miller uh thank
you Mr chairman uh to build on
representative sy's comments uh the
other thing that I would note here um is
as we heard in the
testimony this debt is typically
incurred by force most times the person
having that vehicle towed does not get
to choose the company that tow it or
what that rate is going to be they can't
shop it around they are subject to a
contract typically between the local uh
police department or authorities there
and who they call for the towing and so
as we've talked about in various other
bills in this committee um being forced
into a contract with a private entity by
the government and as a result of that
losing your license which for most of us
means losing your ability to work uh
seems uh especially unfair um and yeah I
I would also add that I got the email
from the towing companies as well um I
feel like it probably would have
behooved them to show up and testify if
they wanted to have their that opinion
felt more broadly by the committee
rather than having it sort of thrown in
last
minute thank
you anybody
else actually I'll just chime in a
little bit I don't fall out of your
chair but I actually agree with you um
in the fact that I I originally was
looking at a retain on this only because
I believe there are other things things
in the statute that could be addressed
um I don't think this bill does it as
written uh in having conversations about
germanness and the possibility of
working on it without this bill uh we
can do that for something introduced
freestanding next year so for that I'm
not going to support this but I do agree
with you that I think the statute with
the forc or being compelled to use
certain companies for the towing
probably needs to be looked at so uh
again with that I think future future
work is good I don't think we need this
particular language I'll be supporting
the itl anybody else from the
committee seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the rule when she's ready motion
is inexpedient to
legislate Vice chairman Gorski yes clerk
votes yes representative Hill yes
representative foot yes representative
ATA yes representative Leon yes
representative GID no representative
Hamlin yes representative Sykes no
representative n no representative Fox
no Representative auu no representative
Gerard no Representative pandon no
representative Miller no and chairman
Walsh
uh the motion of in expedient to
legislate fails 8 to8 is there another
motion our options being uh in OTP or
retain yes Mr chairman I make a motion
of a to pass
for all the previous dated reasons I
again okay uh motion is on to pass is
there a second representative Miller do
we need any further discussion seeing
none I'll ask the clerk to call the
Vice chairman M Gorski
no clerk votes no representative Hill no
representative foot no Representative
pataro no representative Lon no
representative
gon representative Hamlin no
representative Sykes yes representative
n yes representative Fox yes
representative veu yes representative
Gerard yes representative pondon yes
representative Miller yes and chairman
Walsh
no eight
to this may come as a
shocker the motion of V to pass fails 8
to8 we're running out of motions is
there one representative guys a motion
to
retain excuse me um retains been moved
seconded by
representative vu uh I'm sure we don't
need anymore but I'll make I'll give the
option seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
the vice chairman Gorski yes clerk votes
yes representative Hill yes
representative foot yes representative
Taro yes representative Leon yes
representative gon yes representative
Hamlin yes representative Sykes yes
representative new yes representative
Fox yes representative veu yes
representative Gerard yes representative
panden yes representative Miller yes and
chairman Walsh yes 16 to zero uh the
motion to retain is adopted 16 Z I'll
close the executive session on House
Bill
all right I'll open up the executive
session on House Bill 441 relative to
visible motor vehicle diesel emission
and quote unquote rolling
Cole uh chair
recognizes representative gon for motion
thank you Mr chair I move inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 441 motions
inexpedient to legislate do I have a
second by representative foot care to
speak to your motion sir yes sir thank
you Mr chair so under current code of
law this is already illegal this this
law actually does nothing you're not
allowed to modify the um the fuel intake
exhaust Etc on a private vehicle to the
point where it would violate the OBD and
emission standards and that is exactly
what this law says is that you're not
allowed to do that so it's already
codified into law to me this is just uh
it's it's frivolous in that it's just
exists thank you sir I agree completely
this is the second time we've seen this
bill in two years and the same argument
was made last time anybody else from the
committee representative flet thank you
Mr chairman uh just to add to that and
it's uh an EPA violation as well so it's
it's federally regulated
so yep anybody else seeing that motion
is in expedient to legislate on House
Bill
441 I'll ask the clerk to call the role
when she's
ready Vice chairman Gorski yes clerk
votes yes representative Hill yes
representative foot yes representative
ataro yes representative Leon yes
representative gon yes representative
Hamlin yes representative Sykes yes
representative n yes representative Fox
yes representative veu yes
representative Gerard yes representative
pandon yes representative Miller yes and
zero yep uh um so our recommendation of
inexpedient to legislate is adopted 160
I heard consent any objection to consent
seeing none consent it'll be I'll close
the executive session on house bille
441 and a couple minutes to reset we'll
all right let's just Dive Right In I'll
open up the executive session on House
Bill 461 relative to the Department of
Safety and Department of Motor Vehicle
training and testing m materials chair
recognizes representative Gorski for a
motion thank you Mr chair uh my motion
is for OTP on HB
461 motion is out to pass second I'll
second Mr second it by representative
pyro and I'll take this one for you Mr
Vice
chair okay uh first I'll apologize for
not making the uh public hearing on this
um but I'll just explain why I filed
this Bill uh it started uh when I saw
that the department of safety had gone
to the executive Council seeking Monies
to spend taxpayer funds on providing all
the testing materials and testing or
training materials and testing for the
Hampshire driver licenses that just was
my my first issue with this whole thing
I just why are the taxpayers being
footing the bill for for this um but
then as I started digging into it um a
few things happened which just
solidified um why I did this and and why
I was glad I did this
actually first of all we we had a rash
of uh wrongway
crashes on our interstates and I've
already had the discussion I I told him
I was going to mention it and at 5:00 in
the morning I was watching the news and
uh Lieutenant storm got on TV explaining
these and said we've got three problems
going on with the roads in New Hampshire
right now we have impairment we have
distraction which we know that's why we
just took care of the secondary fence
for for for cell phones and we have a
language problem and it it's true um
right now the the signs on our roads are
all in English we also have a statute
that
says that we use English and all our our
public documents if we TR we hear it all
the time that we are truly here about
safety reasons and that why I put the
bill in again it truly doesn't make
sense to me that if you cannot speak
English that you drive on the roads of
the state and get a driver's license and
and get
assisted um in um getting that
license just as a matter of Common Sense
too because I've been called xenophobe
I've been called racist I've been seeing
the emails from the week that is
couldn't be anything further from the
truth just to illustrate that this is
safety and Common Sense even
our feder Federal Motor Carrier safety
regulations currently
State um that a person is qualified to
drive a commercial motor vehicle if he
or she quote can read and speak the
English language sufficiently to
converse with the general public to
understand highway traffic signs and
signals in the English language to
respond to official inquiries and to
make entries on reports and Records I
didn't make this up I didn't make this
concept up this has apparently been a
common sense issue for a lot of years uh
if if it applies for the commercial side
of our driver's licenses I don't
understand why it wouldn't apply to
passenger vehicles as well to go one
step further if you look around the
planet there are a lot of countries that
that that actually have their street
signs in multiple languages if we think
it's a good idea to have people that
cannot speak an ounce of English driving
in this the state then perhaps we should
put a bill in next year to put it
separate language or language is on
every street sign in New Hampshire then
that takes this whole argument
away um again I mentioned is already in
statute uh just that language is is
recognized as our official language in
New Hampshire and as of yesterday uh by
executive action it is now the language
recognized by the federal government uh
I'll leave it at that for now again this
is common sense this has got nothing to
do with racism it's got nothing to do
with
xenophobia uh and I really enjoyed these
emails this truly is common sense so
that being said any any body else from
the
committee representative
pataro thank you Mr chair I just wanted
to Echo the last bullet point you made
that um one of the legal concerns I did
have at the time of our hearing was that
again the United States federal
government didn't have an official
language at that time over the past
couple of weeks our president and
administration did make English the
official language of this country and
that does have profound ramifications
such as something like this bill So
Satisfied I um just wanted to add
that um anybody else from the committee
representative Miller thank you Mr
chairman
um I could not disagree with you more uh
on the reasoning the justification or
the value that this bill
brings um citing commercial regulations
and suggesting that should apply to
personal driver's licensees
non-commercial is a red herring um of
absurd proportions there are several
things that apply to commercial drivers
that do not apply to personal drivers
that there's a reason we have different
licenses for them suggesting that a
federal commercial license policy should
apply to a regular driver's license uh
at the State of New Hampshire level
is an
unreasonable uh let's say approach to
um I would dispute that the problem with
people driving the wrong way on the
interstate is because they can't read
these
signs
uh there are Myriad indicators
associated with Street navigation road
navigation it is not just the words on
the sign a stop sign is a stop sign
because it is a red octagon with a white
border on it it is not a stop sign
because it has the word stop written
stop in the middle of it if any of us
went to France and were driving in
France or the French Caribbean islands
or anywhere else where France is the
native language and saw a red octagon
with a white border on it that said a RR
e with a little hat on it t we would
know that that is a stop sign despite
the fact that it has the word aret
written there Canada to they do it there
um Quebec at least uh right a one-way
sign is not a one-way sign because it
says oneway in the middle of it it's a
oneway sign because it's a black sign
with a white arrow pointing that
direction do not enter all of these
signs are pictograms for the precise
reason that language is not
Universal
we finally I will only note that we have
heard from the Department of Safety that
having these multiple language uh tests
available has in fact enabled people to
safely and reasonably acquire a license
to participate in our society and while
you may want everyone to speak English
here in New Hampshire or in the United
States that is quite frankly is a
xenophobic
approach it is not a reasonable
expectation um whether on a temporary or
permanent basis people are here and they
will speak other languages as well our
goal should be to meet our constituents
and Community where they are and help
them to ensure that they have a safe
environment and they can safely
participate in our society not exclude
them for the sake of a language thank
you sorry one last bit we've already
paid the money there's no sense in
throwing away something we've already
paid for you want to talk about wasting
taxpayer dollars we've already paid for
this throwing it away at this point is a
you well first of all we've actually had
somebody as I mentioned from the of
safety recognize the language is a
barrier and with that I ask you a
question uh do you know how to to read
caution black eyes ahead in
Swahili probably not and so I would
suggest that somebody that speaks
Swahili would not be able to read
caution black eyes ahead in English
either we do have our our changeable
safety signs all over the state I I do
consent that language is important uh I
see representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman uh
last week I spent the weekend the azors
um I do not speak
Portuguese
um after riding around on on tours on
the tour bus I asked my wife
uh to conduct a little game with me if
we would um have driven the same way the
tour bus did and there were more times
when they had the pictogram up that we
had no clue what the hell they were
saying in the pictogram um for that
reason we declined to rent a car when
the tours ended um it was just not safe
in my estimation so I have to believe
the reverse is true um that when people
come here that uh that speak a language
other than what our signs are in um that
too is is unsafe unsafe for them as well
as for um the motoring public uh that
does understand the the uh language um
on our signs so for that reason I'll be
461 represent
SES thank you Mr chairman so several
points that I would like to make one um
I've said this before and I think I and
I'll say it again um ours is an aging
State and we would like I would think to
want to encourage persons to move here
particularly young people
professionals people Etc in the last
senses for the first time in many
decades New
Hampshire achieved a positive rate of
population growth that's significant and
is important because because of who's
going to take care of of us as we age
who's going to do the hard manual labor
who's going to do the health care needs
who's going to do there's a whole
variety of industries that depend on uh
labor from for these people who are
coming in and high-tech companies of
which is the one of the foundational
successes of the uh New Hampshire uh
Advantage quote unquote um because those
high-tech companies are hiring people
who come from other places to to live
and work even if it's
temporarily many of them often decide to
stay in any event um my personal
experience has been that uh I've driven
in multiple countries and
um I felt re reasonably safe in fact
very safe because
most s most not all but most signs are
in fact pictograms throughout the world
there are exceptions to that of course
so I view this bill as
um
discriminatory I view it as a waste of
taxpayer dollars I view it as an
anti-business bill because it will make
it harder for companies to recruit the
PE the very people who are filling the
Gap to provide labor
residents who are younger people who are
really invested in their Community um
why would we do that why would we disarm
ourselves so to speak by passing a a
bill that will just make it more and
more difficult for people to come here I
me represent P thank you Mr chairman um
my opposition to this bill is based on
conversation I had with my neighbor he's
an he's a retired executive from Bae and
one of the biggest problems they're
having what they've had in the last 10
years is getting the scientists they
need to come in from overseas or the
graduates the foreign graduates even
though many of the scientists speak very
good English and are fully capable of of
reading any kind of sign they have
family that may not um they don't feel
comfortable here they they uh
the they understand the pictograms they
understand the signs they understand how
to drive the the most of the things we
use are Universal although Europe has
standardized it far more than we have um
U so to me I agree with with
representative syes that this is would
be an anti-business Bill and it would
communicate to the world that New
Hampshire is closed to any kind of tech
business because a very large number of
of tech scientists are not native americ
you know not not
uh native English speaking
so I like I don't need to repeat the
other things that were already said so
uh I guess I'll just leave it at
that hold on hold on we're GNA go around
the room first before I do repeats
representative Gorski thank you Mr
chairman
um for many people in this room who were
here
last uh last year um they know the story
that I recently found some family down
in
Poland and they one they have done a lot
of work with you know with the refugees
from Ukraine uh
Ukraine but I've gotten to know them and
they've filled in a lot of my family
history my father died very young he
came from Poland he was picked up by the
German Army and was forced to in a forc
labor
camp to make food for the
Germans my father came to this
country and started a
life and as I was growing
up you know I asked my mom like how come
we don't have a car how
come dad doesn't
uncomfortable driving because he didn't
know our
language and he was more concerned with
making sure that if he got behind a
wheel that myself my brother my mom my
family were
English and when he did that's when he
went to get his license
to drive a
car and he felt very proud to know that
now he was behind the
wheel protecting his
family so when people say because I
support this V Ma xob I'm not take
offense to
that because my father lived this I live
this and many of you see me with this
Bavarian jacket I I did this and got
this jacket when I did some business in
Bavaria as a homage to my father to have
my father with me anytime I'm here in
legislation because he died when I was
very young so my father lived
this
and I look back and I appreciate back
then I didn't because I was like Dad I
want to go drive around let's go because
other families did that but I learned
from my cousin in which he wrote letters
stating the reason why that's why I'm
anybody else from the committee
representative I haven't heard from
pandon yet representative pandon thank
you Mr chair my other concern with this
is listening to the the debate going on
and I'm thinking weekly now I'm getting
a dozen to 20 handwritten letters from
people in the
ESL uh uh classes
with their fears that ESL funding is
going to go by the wayside so if we
can't teach
English this all seems
moo because
it's I don't know the details of it I
haven't uh reached out to these teachers
in the ESL program uh in nashwa but it's
a it's a concern it's a fear that the
the funding is going to stop on the the
the training of this
so if we can't teach them how to speak
English then the it's going to be harder
for them to to pass drive a zed as well
that's just my concern on this and it's
just something that just came to my mind
on the number of handwritten letters I'm
getting so hopefully it's a valid point
representative gas thank you Mr chair so
one of the things that I want to pay
attention to specifically with this bill
is it's who we're giving a New Hampshire
driver's license to it doesn't restrict
anything else so you can drive on an
international permit or a tourist permit
for 3 to six months anywhere in the
United States that very state to state
when you're talking about giving
somebody a state ID they're expressly
intending to stay here so I think that
it's fair at that point to say yes you
know you you you've got three to six
months under your International learn
enough English to uh to get the driver's
license because you're now going to be a
resident here and part of transitioning
into a country is learning the language
and the culture and you know you're not
talking about somebody who's coming out
here for two or three month uh weeks
you're talking about somebody who's
going to be living here for an extended
period of time so I I support the intent
of this
Bill thank you sir anybody else from the
committee um I forget who was first I
should have written it down I'll go this
way pataro thank you Mr chair and thank
you for recognizing me again
um uh briefly going back to the point
about this always being in um Federal
rules and it especially pertains to
um the commercial Trucking industry in a
sense
um when in if you're that kind of Drive
you're a commercial driver it's like
imperative that you literally read
everything that happens as it's coming
at you it's imperative it it's important
for safety it's important so they can
navigate it's important so we can the
State can enforce its own laws too um
this bill is about the DMV's testing
materials and you know one one sense
that I have about about this is that we
don't want to set people up for failure
either so
um we have a language and we have our
entire infrastructure configured around
that language and it should be in
alignment thank you
anybody else representative Miller thank
you for the opportunity to address the
body again um a few bits of comments
that have come up that I would like to
speak to directly uh with regard to uh
not feeling comfortable driving with the
pictographs in a foreign country um
the law here would not be that you would
simply show up and be given a
license the law as it exists today is
that we provide you with the training
materials in the language that you
understand if you show if I showed up in
a random place and the signs were all
different I too would not want to drive
there but if I intended to drive there I
would take the course I would review the
materials I would learn what they
mean hopefully in a language that I
actually understand and then be
qualified to safely operate on the roads
so yes some signs may be different from
where they start these people started
their Driving Experience but the goal
here is to give them the opportunity to
learn not to Simply say go at it um I
respect your father's decision to not
drive um while he felt unsafe about
it we have changed our policies in this
state to allow people to learn these
things in their native language we don't
know if if the if it was available in
German I assume um or polish you brought
up the Varian also I wasn't sure sorry
um I guess from the before times of Bas
sorry uh if uh if it was available in
Polish would he have felt more
comfortable we probably don't know um
but again making it so that residents of
New Hampshire are comfortable and able
to have that experience and do so safely
means meeting our constituents where
they are um finally uh to the point of
people should just learn English and get
their license um and be
here I'm not good at foreign languages
so I'm probably not the best example of
this but I don't know anyone who can
pick up a foreign language in two months
and feel fluently comfortable in it that
is a extreme expectation to have and the
law as it exists in New Hampshire is
that within two months of arrival if you
intend to be a resident here you will
acquire a driver
license and so um the idea here is that
they could just learn English and get
over it um it's not going to happen that
fast and in the interim period as I
alluded to before we are going to have a
situation where these people cannot work
cannot run errands cannot participate in
the businesses with our businesses or
for our businesses we are shunning them
from society by taking this approach and
I strongly urge you to reject removing
accessibility for our residents thank
you anybody
else represent
Crawford so I'm I'm really torn on this
bill because I I understand um
everybody would love to be able to speak
English I'm I'm assuming when they come
to this country and when they come to
this state and I know in driver
education uh industry which I'm a part
of um we've tried to make it easier for
instructors to be able to communicate
with their students and not all not all
kids coming here legally um can speak
the language as fluently as we would
like so I know it doesn't affect me in
my uh area because I'm like up in the
north country and I to be honest with
you don't have um any I I I think in all
the years that I've teach T Drive visit
like 27 years I've never had a student
that didn't communicate English to me I
didn't have it but I know that in the
southern part of this state it's it's a
problem and the instructors in the
southern part of the state um were
asking for this type of um
um instruction to help them communicate
with their
students I don't know what I'm going to
do to be honest with you so I'm I'm just
going to sit here and I I hope somebody
else
would pipe in because I I get what
chairman Walsh I respect chairman Walsh
with all all the respect in the world
and I understand where he's coming from
but I don't know if I totally agree with
eliminating all of the
um languages that the people who want to
stay here and be here um if they need
that as a boost to get to that point of
understanding English and being able to
speak it I just don't know if we're
taking that away so that's all I have to
say any any body else actually I'll ask
representative land do you still have
the statute
handy um yes let me pull that up um and
um since you're having me speak I do
want to note that I went to when I went
to Poland for my friend's wedding um one
of the most offensive things you could
do there was speak German because most
of the Polish people who speak German
did not learn it by choice
um sorry I know it's an decide and we're
trying to stay focused but um here in
RSA 3-c colon one it says the official
language of the State of New Hampshire
shall be English English is designated
as the language of all official public
documents and records and of all public
proceedings and non-public
sessions thank you represent
s thank
you not withstanding
that I would remind everybody that many
countries have official
languages but in those
countries often times the majority of
the public speak a different language it
and what we're what we don't want to do
is use that as a tool to keep people
from advancing in their life and
integrating
into um a
population and being productive members
of society and this
right now again I would reiterate um the
point that this allows people it helps
people to learn so that they can take a
test and gain the driver's privileges
that they are required to have if
they're going to remain here as
residents so I I think we just need to
know I my experience for
instance and we've talked a lot about
that that but um one of the countries
that I worked in for several years
actually the official language was
French 90% of the population did not
speak French and yet they
all actually drove quite safely um and
had no greater accident rate than we do
here in the United States um because I
was curious about that and asked
actually
anybody else ripson blon uh thank you Mr
chairman um actually my friend who was
married in Poland grew up in Poland and
she came to the United States as a child
and she learned English very quickly I
think the idea that people can't learn
English I understand it's a difficult
language but I also think it's a bigotry
of low expectations to tell people that
you're not going to be able to learn
English so we're not going to expect
that of you um I I think that high
expectations are good and um I'm I'm
always concerned when people are othered
and people suggest that they can't learn
things and they're not as smart as
native Native English speakers that
always bothers me because that's really
else go ahead representative Miller
thank you m Mr
chairman uh no one is suggesting that
learning English can't be done um or
that it's imp possible to do or that
anyone who is trying to learn English is
dumber or less capable than anyone else
the point made is that doing it in two
months to a level of fluency that allows
you to take a driver's
unreasonable anybody
else representative pataro um thank you
once again Mr chair um uh before I say
what I want to say just
ress this is about the training
materials but um if since we're all on
the topic of um this very fascinating
subject is it is in my belief that um
anybody on the planet learning English
does nothing but to boost their um
opportunities when it comes to improving
themselves or their economic
opportunities or anything um English is
a very very important language not just
here in New Hampshire the United States
but
globally it is and I I reject the notion
that just because you need to speak
English here that somehow if you can't
you're going to be shunned from society
uh my grandparents my M and pepe
actually came here they couldn't speak a
word of English and they actually M
melted into society very easily so uh
anybody else in the committee I know
we're anything new on on the bill
itself well okay
now for the good news this bill is open
for further
Amendment and I have an
amendment because this bill deals with
the the training and testing materials
and you can thank somebody for emailing
me and reminding me that well this has
nothing to do about with translators so
this bill this amendment will deal with
translators I'll give you a few minutes
to pass it out and read it and we can
give up your office yep no you know what
fair enough um It's been a it's been a
lengthy debate we have a fresh amendment
to look at uh we will take a break um
need uh by this clock which says 11:15
we'll we'll reconvene we end our break I
should say I gotta be careful how we say
this um at
11:30 uh we'll discuss the amendment
take up the amendment and then then
11:30
e
okay welcome back
folks I'm going to
resume our executive session on House
Bill
461 as I said before we took a little
break this this uh bill is open for
further Amendment the chair recognize
representative
Gorski thank you Mr chairman um I move
to open up uh Amendment uh 2025 5- 0471
H for
consideration okay so amendment 0471 has
been moved is there a second seconded by
represent Hamlin thank you sir I'll take
over for
you uh this amendment actually was an
unintentional Omission from the original
bill um again with the original bill
uh testing materials training and
testing materials um but in hindsight
looking back at it when you allow
translators in-person translators or
using apps or even computer
programs um it's actually even worse
than than the the training itself now
you're you're just helping somebody get
through the test knowing full well that
they have no grasp of the English
language and I know we talked about the
the pictogram science that are the
common ones for stop and One Way etc etc
but there were so many more things on
the roads that require somebody in my
opinion for complete safety to be able
to read including directional signs um
you see it now um you know people don't
can't read the sign or don't understand
the sign the first thing they do is lock
up the brakes they don't look for a
place to pull over it's it's it's our I
guess and all I'm trying to say is our
roads we can all see with our own eyes
are not getting safer nowadays they're
getting a little bit more treacherous
and why we don't do what we can do to at
least dress one of the reasons for it um
I think would be a mistake so so I offer
this amendment and again it's pretty
simple um it just uh amends I would say
263 6E paragraph 5 uh you can read for
yourselves you don't need me to go
through it one at a time to make sure
that those things are not allowed in
this whole process either in terms of
translators as I said with translation
apps computer programs Etc it still does
allow devices to use and Aid in people
with hearing or seeing the English
language or seeing American Sign
Language those those are not affected
and still shall be shall still be
permitted so um that's what the
amendment does I'll open it up to the
committee representative SES thank you
Mr chairman so it's my considered
opinion that this amendment um
particularly the first piece of
removing uh an in-person
translator
um makes the
bill more egregious than its original
version and my question to the committee
and to the members as we Ponder the the
incredible significance of what we're
doing here today
is when will we stop who will we then
who is next on that list to be um having
more difficulty to to ACH achieve the
privilege of driving I I worry about
that
significantly um I think that this is
just we're going down a we're going down
a road that I don't think is uh is
appropriate or
sustainable uh in the long run for the
economic and uh for the the economic
health for the uh strength of our
society for the strength of the vision
that is the United States which is to be
open and welcoming to as many people as
we can and I I just I can't support the
amendment nor can I and even with the
amendment nor could I support the
bill ripson gon thank you Mr chair in
looking at the amendment I I actually
I favor it um for one reason and that's
safety um I was talking with with a
State Trooper on the break and you know
and I asked the question what does it
mean when you pull somebody over that
your officer can't communicate with and
the the the basic answer that I got was
more time on the side of the road which
exposes both the civilian and the
officer to higher risk of a road strike
or anything else while the officer has
to use some kind of a translator and
that it lengthens stops um so again
we're talking about who we give instate
licenses to not not Travelers Not
tourists not instate licenses and if
we're giving instate licenses to people
who can't basically verbally communicate
in English especially at the side of the
road um on a routine traffic stop or you
know forbidden accident um we're
creating a barrier that will lengthen
the amount of time again that there is
exposure to traffic both for our law
enforcement officers and for those
civilians anybody El
raro thank you Mr chair um across
entire Industries and spectrums there's
um certifications examinations and you
know the DMV Proctors the examinations
for the license and um there are other
aspects
that
we legislate and oversee and so forth
but but we want to make sure that um
they're able to Proctor these exams
correctly this amendment lists several
things and we also want to make sure
that none of these things that could be
allowed could be used for any nefarious
cheating let's say on the
examination so I think we need to um
consider that as well thank
you anybody
else one thought represent SES thank you
um
actually um the problem with the last
minute amendments is it doesn't give
anybody uh a real opportunity
to talk to their professionals who would
also would be responsible for
administering the program and um and I
don't expect that to happen today and
wouldn't even ask for it to happen today
but I I I have to ask myself the
question and I would wish that you would
ask yourselves the question would
be during the actual driving test that
the person has to demonstrate that they
are competent to receive the privilege
of
driving what role does the translator
actually play in making that
determination I don't think any that
can't be a short answer today and I
don't think we have an answer and so I I
anybody
else seeing none we'll take up the
amendment first I usually do a Voice
vote on that but we will do a roll call
on the amendment I'll give the clerk a
ready
yep Vice chairman Gorski hold on me go
so this is uh to adopt amendment number
0471 H I'll ask the clerk to call the
role thank you repres uh vice president
uh VI president
President
congratulations Vice
chairman Vice chairman Cori yes the
clerk will vote Yes representative Hill
yes representative foot yes
representative pataro yes representative
Lon yes representative gas yes
representative Hamlin yes representative
Sykes no representative n no
representative Fox no representative Au
no representative Gerard no
Representative pandon no representative
yes nine to to seven so the amendment is
adopted 9 to7 uh the motion now on the
floor is U ought to pass on House Bill
461 as
amended anybody care to speak on the
U yeah you know what in summary I think
we can all recognize that part of what
we do here is about
safety we all know that we have an issue
with impairment we've been asked to go
to roundtables here and there with
sometimes even the executive counselors
to find and address ways to deal with
impairment we know distraction has been
an issue for years and even us as a as a
committee a few minutes ago recommended
not going backwards in time by making
distracted driving with cell phones uh a
secondary offense uh I didn't make up
the language barrier we all know this is
an issue we I heard somebody say going
down the road well we've been going down
this road for four years you know
language has always probably been an
issue in this country but but when when
it's a limited thing the odds of
something happening are pretty low the
higher the number the higher the chances
of bad things happening and that's all
this build is trying to address uh one
step further I think the practice that's
being taken uh the practice that's been
going on right now uh was not well it
was not done legislatively it was not
done through this committee it was done
through rules I assume but based on the
statute that we heard I'm not even sure
if it uh if it's
statutory so with all those things um
I'm um hoping you'll support House Bill
461 as amended and we'll try to take
care of another issue going on on our
roads I'll ask the clerk to call the
role when she's ready motion is ought to
amended ice chairman Gorski yes the
clerk will vote Yes representative Hill
yes yes representative foot yes
representative pataro yes representative
Lon yes representative G yes
representative Hamlin yes representative
Sykes no representative n no
representative Fox no representative FAO
no representative Gerard no
Representative pandon no representative
Miller no chairman Walsh yes 9
to7 committee's recommendation of V to
pass was amended is adopted 9 to 7
regular C there it'll go I'll close a
uh we have five bills left consensus
okay that being said open up the
executive session and Hospital 489
allowing volunteer emergency workers to
use rear-facing blue lights on their
private Vehicles when involved in
emergency
representative pataro for a motion thank
you Mr chair I move itl on House Bill
489 motion is inexpedient to legislate
do I have a second seconded by
representative Crawford care to speak
your motion sir uh yes thank you Mr
chair
um uh this bill would um
allow volunteers to install a uh blue
light to their vehicles when um these
volunteers are responding uh the reason
I believe it should be ited is because
blue lights
are clearly indicative of uh police
officers and our police force um I
understand in the past that we did make
changes to allow blue lights on um
emergency vehicles such as ambulances
and fire trucks to the motoring public
there's no ambiguity with those types of
vehicles being uh Emer Mercy vehicles
but when we have volunteers using their
um day-to-day vehicles and we we already
allow them to use the uh red lights but
when we start using the blue lights I
feel
that encroaches on the work that our
police force does and um it can be very
confusing and frankly um distracting and
disheartening for the motoring public if
they're getting out of the way of what
what they might be may or may not be
believed the the right kind of response
so with that I think I think it's best
to just um deny this
request well put representative pataro
anybody else from the
committee
represent thank you Mr
chairman um so we did recently in fact
allow a single red light on the back of
fire trucks and there was a very good
blue excuse me thank you a blue light on
the back of fire trucks and there was a
very good reason for that and the reason
was that it is a easil more easily seen
and recognized as an emergency than red
lights which can possibly blend in with
tail lights and so on so if we I'm going
to keep this very brief if we
were if we are going to be concerned
about the motoring public public and
their safety and we're going to be
concerned particularly about
volunteer
firefighters or emergency responders and
that's who this bill applies to and
their response
to uh emergency scenes when they may get
there before the ambulance and before
the fire truck because they respond in
their personal vehicles why would we not
now after
having why would we not now want to
support their safety and the safety of
public represent foot thank you Mr
chairman uh I believe during our
testimony we heard from a law
enforcement official that the public
perception people will be desensitized
to to the blue lights so I I believe uh
that also be true so I support the
itl yeah and to that I believe it was
last year we passed a law that would
also prevent Uber and R share companies
from displaying lights as well for the
same reason anybody else from the
committee representative V thank you Mr
chairman uh very quickly um I will
probably defer to the the members of of
Public Safety fire um offices uh because
this is just a rear light and we're
already concerned about the safety on
the side of the road uh we we know that
when they're on the side of the highway
that Vehicles very often get crashed
into from behind uh by people not paying
attention people mistaking the lights
for for brake lights instead of uh safe
Public Safety officials um if this helps
with visibility and helps save lives I'm
going to support
it anybody else from the committee and
just just just another thought too I
mean the desensitizing you of a blue
light can occur without them even being
on if there there are these blue lights
on passenger vehicles all over the state
even just in traffic not on people will
see them and understand that well maybe
the next time they see one lit it really
it doesn't do much must be another
passenger vehicle so anyway I'll be uh
supporting the itl anybody else from the
committee seeing n Al last the clerk to
call the role when she's ready the
motion is in expedient to
legislate Vice chairman Gorski yes the
clerk votes yes representative Hill yeah
representative foot yes representative
pataro yes representative Lon yes yes
representative GID yes representative
Hamlin yes representative Sykes no
representative n no representative Fox
no representative a no representative
panden yes representative Miller no and
yes 10 to
five that's it
oh I'm sorry six thank you our
recommendation of in expedient to
legislate is adopted 106 I'll close the
executive session on House
Bill uh
489 um we'll continue in order House
I'll open up the executive session on
House Bill 533 relative to the use of
Civilian employees and commercial truck
inspections J
recognizes representative Hamlin for a
motion thank you Mr chair I'd like to
make a motion that this bill ought to
second second second by I Ser represent
guon first I care to speak to your
motion sir uh thank you Mr chance uh so
yes what this bill is asking is that
when a uh police officer goes in to do
an inspection on a commercial operation
uh the the police officer is can do you
know P look at the paperwork look at the
operation but as far as doing any type
of inspection on a vehicle to make sure
that the vehicles are being inspected
properly it takes a trained person and
for this for this reason uh to be able
to take a civilian in to do that type of
an operation or an inspection I believe
um seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the rule when she's ready uh the
motion is OD to pass on
5:33 Vice chairman Gorski yes clerk
votes yes representative Hill yes
representative foot yes representative
patara yes representative Lon yes
representative gon yes representative
Hamil yes representative Sykes no
representative n no representative Fox
no representative
Veo no representative Gerard no
representative Panda no representative
Miller no and chairman Walsh no
oh
[Music]
okay 8 to eight
done uh the motion of a to pass did the
right
thing I always do representative SS uh
our motion of a to pass fails 88 is
there a motion you know the two that we
yeah why not CH chair recognizes
representative SES yeah I make a motion
to
retain retains the motion do we have a
second seconded by representative G get
speaking motion or
n up to you no um I ever so briefly
would suggest that um I think this is
another one of those questions that
deserves um has some good points we the
notes in front of me have pros and cons
it isn't you know and so maybe we need
to look at that and have it take use
that opportunity to see if we can uh
refine it if we can hence retain fair
enough anybody else from the
committee represent gon yeah I really I
really wanted this to pass but um but
you know if it's if it's not going to
pass then we should retain it the do you
know specifically asked us to look at
this so that they could have more
resources for inspections and because
it's a civilian contractor working for
the dot I don't think that they would be
less qualified than the system that we
have in place right now so it it becomes
an issue of Manpower so I'd rather
retain it and clean the language up than
kill
it fair enough and I'll be honest that's
why I I did not vote for the aop pass
it's just been my personal experience
with the civilians that haven't been
inspecting these stations that I think
we need to look at the whole the whole
picture so retain fair enough anybody
else from the committee seeing that I'll
ask the clerk to call the rooll motion
is to
retain Vice chairman Gorski yes clerk
votes yes representative Hill yes
representative foot yes representative
Taro yes representative Leon yes
represent representative GID yes
representative HBL yes representative
Sykes yes representative du yes
representative Fox yes representative Au
yes representative Gerard yes
representative pund yes representative m
yes and chairman wsh
yes 16 to zero I have a recommendation
to retain and to hold on to it is
adopted 160 I'll close the executive
session on H Bill
533 um next up give us a moment H Bill
you go ahead represent Miller uh not
specific to this debate but with 414
earlier where we and I'm sorry never
all right I'll open up the executive
session on House Bill 594 relative to
the definition of
away chair recognizes representative
Hill for a motion thank you Mr chairman
I would move OTP ought to pass on House
Bill 594 oh I'm sorry
it looking at the wrong one and speaking
out loud thank you itl on House Bill
594 understandable we've had a good
morning here uh motion is inexpedient to
legislate is there a
second that's it second representative
Crawford I heard her first um did you
care to speak your motion would you
defer I've done such a good job this
morning I think I will uh defer to
representative Leon okay uh
understandable uh chair recognizes
representative Leon uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
Hill um this this bill was introduced in
order to repeal a section of my bill
right to moow which we had passed last
year which would which remove the
prohibitions on people doing things like
driving riding lawnmowers when they had
their license suspended for being a
about doing a very bad thing like
getting a DUI um this section of it was
probably the most difficult part of the
language that I wrote but a lot of
people don't know where the actual edge
of their property ends legally and a lot
of people think that their property goes
up to their edge of their grass without
having a definition of way that
basically says if you mow between the
legal edge of your property and the edge
of the grass um that that's acceptable
otherwise we're putting people at risk
of spending seven nights in jail for not
knowing the edge of their property or
the property that they're mowing as a
landscaper um I had initially come in to
speak on the bill the prime sponsor
didn't come to the hearing um I spoke um
asking for an itl on this bill however I
did understand that there were some
concerns um from some people within the
agencies within the Department of
Justice I never I asked and reached out
I wanted to know what the specific
concerns were so that instead of killing
the bill we could correct their concerns
with the language I never got anything
concrete from them so I think that we
should itl the bill but I'd like to keep
the offer open that if we have any
language to make this more clear I will
put in the bill next year or the year
after that in order to make sure that
this does what I intend and it doesn't
have any unintended consequences of the
bill that's already in law um so with
that I'd ask everybody to vote itl on
this
Bill thank you representative anybody
else from the
committee see none I'll ask the clerk to
call the role when she's ready the
motion is inexpedient to
legis Vice chairman Gorski yes clerk
votes yes representative Hill yes
representative foot yes representative
pataro yes representative Lon yes
representative G yes representative
Hamlin yes representative Sykes yes
representative n yes representative Fox
yes representative Veo yes
representative Gerard yes representative
Pand yes representative Miller yep and
chairman Walsh yes 16 Z our
recommendation of inexpedient to
legislators adopted
160 consent any objection to consent
seeing none I'll close the executive
session on H Bill
594 getting down to the wire well
moment
going open up the executive session on
House Bill 6:32 permitting healthc care
providers affiliated with the Veterans
Administration to certify medical
accommodations on behalf of veterans
residing in New Hampshire chair
recognizes representative gason for a
motion thank you Mr chair I move out to
pass and House Bill 632 motions out to
pass seconded by representative Miller
care to speak to your motion sir uh yes
sir thank you Mr chair so again after
speaking with the uh director of the DMV
uh the chief medical officer of the VA
hospital and the adant general of the
State of New Hampshire it was determined
it was easier and faster to move
legislation to um fill a loophole that
was accidentally put in by by the jail
car last year that disqualified out of
state healthcare providers for writing
for medical exceptions so this bill um
would allow the VA to do that whereas
many VA Health Care Providers are
federally contracted here and they're
not licensed by this state but licensed
in other states in the United States to
practice medicine in the United States
but they're here contractually so all
this does is patch that hole very
quickly so that we don't end up in a uh
lawsuit thank you sir anybody else from
the committee
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the role when she's ready the motion is
ought to
pass Vice chairman Gorski yes clerk
votes yes representative Hill yes
representative foot yes representative
pataro yes representative Lon yes
representative G yes representative
Hamlin yes representative Sykes yes
representative n yes representative Fox
yes representative Veo yes
representative Gerard yes representative
Pand yeses Senator Miller yep chairman
Walsh yes 16 16 to
zero uh are recommendation about the
pass is adopted 16 to zero I heard
consent no objections seeing none
consent that is I'll close the hearing
on
6:32 and we have one left uh host Bill
so
all right folks I'm going to open up the
executive session on House Bill 758
establishing a committee to study
airport operation hours chair recognizes
representative patara you going to be
busy this afternoon representative thank
you Mr chair
um I move itl on House Bill 758 you
scared me for a minute is there a second
motion is in expedient to
legislate second second by
representative Miller care to speak to
your motion sir uh yes briefly thank you
um uh this bill would establish um a
committee
legislatively uh um after some
discussions and after the hearing
um the committee believes we believe
that this would be better left to um the
industry to sort out amongst themselves
um they're they're on the ground or in
this case they're in the air or what
have you but they're they're the ones
there who who know the situation best
and we should leave it up to them and
the market to sort out whatever issues
they
have fair enough and anybody else from
the
committee looks like a bunch of people
didn't want to sit on the committee to
study airport operation hours that's
that's very
wise without without seeing any further
discussion I'll ask the clerk to call
the role when she's ready to motion is
inexpedient to
legislate Vice chairman Gorski yes clerk
votes yes representative Hill yes
representative foot yes representative
ataro yes representative Leon yes
representative G yes representative hlin
yes yes representative Sykes yes
representative n yes representative Fox
yes representative Vu yes representative
Gerard yes representative pandon yes
representative Miller yes and chairman
Walsh yes 16 to
[Music]
zero our recommendation of inexpedient
to legislator is adopted 16 to
zero consent consent any objection to
consent seeing none I'll close the
executive session on House Bill 758
and congratulations everybody that is
the last house
bill uh for this year uh and we're
actually done prior to the deadline for
second committee bills so what that does
is basically give us a month off from
committee work yeah because we we may
see Senate bills prior to the crossover
it doesn't happen often but it can but
it's usually very few so I see no need
to call us back until after crossover
um I think we're all set on uh people to
defend the committee reports on
Thursday as far as reports for today
I've got two to do myself I ask
everybody to get them I I need them
today so I don't know if you're going to
take a lunch break and come back that's
fine that's probably what I'll do but I
do need my reports by by the time you
leave um if you need hard copies we have
them in the office otherwise the
electronic template will work with
anything else for the good of the cause
I have copies
too representative craford has copies
too nothing else well thank you again
that'll conclude our business for the